- A lot of cameras, a lot of chaos.
Good energy.
I'm super excited to get on
stage and fucking rip it up.
(inspiring music)
- Literally, I really
think YouTube's favorite,
all-time Daily Vee moment.
I literally cannot believe that.
Like, I sat.
- [Staffer] It was like three
in a row each and then
Tom was like fuck it.
I can't hit this.
Switch.
Underhand.
- This it he worst moment of my life.
To lose to the Rick Barry
underhanded free throw
to make the last spot.
I'm fucking pissed.
Fuck me.
- [Staffer] The backpack kid.
- What, who was funny?
Backpack, backpack, backpack.
- He's really good.
- Backpack, backpack, backpack.
The recall, YouTube.
I'm sure Eric just edited that moment.
Cold DM-ing.
Like, you can literally type
- I've been doing that.
- Yeah, I believe in that the most.
I think it's a complete fucking lay up.
I think you type in Staten Island
or your exact address
on fucking Instagram,
and look, I just, and the hashtag sign,
I don't know what else to tell ya.
I just fundamentally believe in it.
(upbeat music)
I'm just getting off a
call in the London office.
We're gonna be moving offices.
I'm intrigued by a lot of emails
from a lot of you entrepreneurs.
A lot of you peeps on YouTube
about decision making.
My big belief is speed matters there.
You know, it's funny.
Eric's filming today.
Eric Caster who, is a super
important character in my life,
because, fun fact, Eric
was the person that filmed
the first episodes of Wine Library TV,
was our first development hire.
Worked for the outside firm
that built winelibrary.com,
and is really unbelievably,
and disproportionally
responsible for my tech
endeavors, actually,
for that matter.
I mean, I feel like I
would've gotten there anyway,
I assume, and a lot of things
would've happened anyway,
and that's just not how life works.
Eric obviously worked for and with me,
but also for and with my dad.
I love my dad and he's the best,
but I think one of the things to raz
is he just sits on decisions.
It's just his normal demeanor,
and I believe that speed
in making decisions
is super important.
I think it comes down
to perfection, and like,
trying to make the right, perfect call.
And I think that the right, perfect call,
nine out of ten times is the fastest call.
And that doesn't mean
you don't be thoughtful.
It means that you spend
your days, every day,
becoming a practitioner,
becoming great at what you do,
and the beginning you go off of intuition,
but you just don't overthink shit.
This was just a fun little call.
Important decision, new office,
but I'm not gonna overthink it.
Get the macro things in place,
figure out how you're gonna
solve for that problem,
and don't worry about the
twenty percent on the edges
of like is this a problem,
is that a problem,
and so I'm a big big fan
of quick, fast decisions.
Especially if you're informed.
Make calls quicker.
Speed matters.
Quick update.
I'll be gone for the
next two or three hours.
I'm going to a Resy board meeting.
R-E-S-Y.
Please download the app.
Please guys, edit.
The absolute app that you should be using
to pick your restaurants.
An amazing company that we (mumbles)
out of Vayner/RSE, our fund.
Ben Leventhal, the CEO,
from the food space,
has just been crushing it.
Mike Montero, CTO,
co-founder, unbelievable,
lot of fun going into board meetings
when things are really
cruising and rolling,
and really the main board
meeting I have each month
out of all of my investments,
or each quarter, excuse me.
See ya.
Heading to an event that I committed to.
Good day so far.
Just had a two hour meeting with a client
that's on the verge of
going from a solid client
to a phenomenal client where
we lost money on the account
for a year, but it's set up in expectory.
I think that one of the great
things that people don't do,
is they lose up front
to win in the long term.
One step backwards, two steps forward.
Obviously easier when you can afford it,
but even when you can't, that
means you live more humbly.
And living more humbly
is something that people
are not willing to do.
They get their business
going a little bit,
and they go buy a fancy
car, then taking the money
out of the system that
would've allowed them
to make that move.
Think about it.
(rap music)
- What's up guys.
I'm here with the one
and only Gary Vaynerchuk.
- What up!
- It's so exciting cuz I
remember seeing you last year.
It was just awesome seeing you.
It's been a great experience.
I can't believe that.
I've been watching the
footage over and over.
- Did you see that I put up
a recall from the footage?
- Yeah yeah yeah I saw that.
- A couple weeks ago right?
- Yeah that was awesome!
- Dude, you've grown.
You're getting bigger.
You're gonna pass me and dad in a minute.
- Ha, thank you!
- It's been going good?
You've been doing a good job?
- Yeah I've been doing awesome!
I've been killing it.
- Enjoying it?
- Yeah I love it, man.
- I love it, man.
Good luck to ya.
- Thank you
- it's great to see ya.
Every single person here not
downloading the top new app
just to taste what it's like,
in case it impacts your
business, is insane.
Everybody is in the "no" business.
No, I'm not gonna download that new thing.
No, I don't need a Snapchat account.
Instagram followed all those features.
I don't need a Snapchat.
Meanwhile, because of
that, all the action,
and opportunity, is in Snapchat,
because it's all supply
and demand of attention.
So for me, I'm not quite
sure why or how or what.
More importantly, to bring value here,
instead of giving you
my fucking narrative,
my bigger thing is for
you to leave with value.
Why are you saying no?
Why are you so fucking fancy?
Super fun.
Just got done with that.
Probably the most fun for me
in a long time with Daily Vee,
because I wish, and I hope
you don't get too humble
about this and edit this shit out Eric.
For me, Eric witnessing
what he just witnessed,
which is, look, I mean call it what it is.
Entrepreneurship is on
a pedestal right now,
and so there was never
a point that I thought
entrepreneurship would be
that much of a cultural thing
where you could be treated
with that level of fame.
I thought I would be known.
I'm sure I said funny things to Eric,
like everybody's gonna know
me like they know Bill Gates,
or whatever we said back then.
But there's a different thing going on,
and this is definitely
one of the best moments
watching all that chaos
and all those selfies
from Eric's eyes right now,
and thinking back to the,
we literally, this is not a joke guys.
We literally sat closer
than we're sitting right now
at a desk building
winelibrary.com in those days.
It's awfully, awfully
gratifying and feels fun.
For parents, you know
how you see the world
through your kids eyes,
and you see how they
get excited about things
for the first time the
way you did as a kid.
It's super fun to watch you
navigate through this day.
(upbeat music)